Pope Francis has asked for prayers for
his predecessor Pope Benedict who he
says is very sick he made the appeal at
the end of his General audience and then
went to visit Pope Benedict the Vatican
has confirmed that Pope Benedict's
Health has deteriorated in recent hours
in a statement they've said we can
confirm that in the last few hours his
condition worsened due to age the
situation at present is under control
monitored constantly by doctors
I'd like to ask all of you for a special
prayer for Emeritus Pope Benedict who in
silence is sustaining the church
I remind you that he is very sick let's
ask the Lord to comfort him and sustain
him in this testimony of love to the
church to the very end
our Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
has the latest
Benedict has been ill for some time but
the Vatican statement today confirming
that his situation has worsened due to
age that he is being constantly
monitored at the moment and this comes
following a request by Pope Francis
today to the faithful to pray for his
predecessor who says is very sick and he
asked them to ask the Lord to comfort
him to the very end and we understand
from the Vatican Pope Francis then went
to visit his predecessor who continues
to live on the Vatican grounds following
his resignation in 2013. now he was the
first pope to resign in around 600 years
a huge step and it followed
um before that decision concerns about a
leaking Scandal that was happening he
said he stepped down due to ill health
but as I say he continued to live on
Vatican grounds and some have said that
his decision to keep wearing white and
not to revert to his original name has
led to some sort of confusion within the
church at sort of two popes situation
with some of the conservative continuing
to see Pope Benedict as my pope now we
know that the two popes continue to have
a strong friendship that he has been
visited as I say by Pope Francis but
news today from the Vatican that Pope
Benedict's health is continuing to
deteriorate